When it comes to Game of Thrones, certain
episodes might end up leaving us with more
questions than they actually answer.
But - gigantic spoiler warning - the most
recent installment of the fantasy epic's final
season, "The Long Night," did clear up one
massive uncertainty fans have had since the
very beginning of the series: how will the
Night King and his Army of Dead be defeated,
and who will carry out the act?
But just because Game of Thrones revealed
Arya Stark to be the Night King-killer, that
doesn't mean the questions stopped there.
In fact, there's one huge question that no
one seems to be asking after the series' latest
episode.
It's simple, but a real head-scratcher: Why
didn't the Night King die when he was engulfed
in fire?
During the previous episode, dragonfire is
thought to be one of only three ways to kill
a White Walker, along with dragonglass and
Valyrian steel.
"Dragon fire can stop him?"
"I don't know.
No one's ever really tried."
Even with that uncertainty, you'd think a
dude made of ice might still be susceptible
to a flaming attack.
So why was the Night King not turned into
an evil puddle when Daenerys Targaryen called
on Drogon to light the frosted villain aflame?
Game of Thrones expert and professional Thrones
tutor Christopher Williams of Varsity Tutors
has a possible explanation.
Speaking with PureWow, Williams detailed that
the Night King survived the onslaught of fire
and fury from the Mother of Dragons because
the two entities are "polar opposites" and
their powers essentially cancel one another
out.
He explained:
"It was sort of an ice beats fire kind of
thing.
They're two polar opposites, so they can't
really be killed by each other."
If the Night King had lived through the Battle
of Winterfell, his immunity to fire would
certainly have spelled trouble for the people
of Westeros, as the Dragon Queen's most powerful
weapon would be useless against him.
Luckily for literally everyone in the country,
Arya took the tried and true method of killing
a White Walker when she stabbed the Night
King with her catspaw dagger made from Valyrian
steel... using the same method Jon Snow employed
when he brought down a White Walker with Longclaw
in season 5.
In that moment, the Arya ended the Long Night
and the side of the living won the Great War
- but the battle isn't over yet.
The Last War is about to begin, and the North
is preparing to make a move on King's Landing
in an attempt to remove the Mad Queen Cersei
Lannister from the Iron Throne.
Many have speculated that Arya's work isn't
done, and that she'll play a pivotal role
in what's to come on Game of Thrones.
Word amongst fans is that the Night King could
actually be the penultimate Arya victim this
season - and that Cersei herself will suffer
the same consequences the Night King did once
Arya crosses her path.
While some believe that Arya's personal character
arc was meant to end with killing the Night
King, shutting the blue eyes that Melisandre
prophesied she would, others are of the opinion
that shutting Cersei's green eyes forever
is Arya's ultimate goal.
"Blue eyes.
Green eyes.
Eyes you’ll shut forever."
Christopher Williams told Yahoo:
"She has the will to continue the fight and
to be brave.
She's been broken down to nothing and now
she's something.
She's got a purpose and she's definitely got
a goal.
I don't think the Night King was a part of
that agenda.
It was kinda like an on the fly decision.
But I think tactically she's been working
toward killing Cersei."
Now that the Night King and his savage White
Walkers have been vanquished, Arya can shift
her attention to helping bring the fight for
the Iron Throne to a final end.
How she might do that is a mystery for now…
but a girl has only a few names left on her
infamous list.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.